and we have another contester for best
actor of 2010 go guy from Mamma Mia The
King's Speech
so the King's Speech is the story of the
Duke of York who would become King
George the six it would become a time of
war the United Kingdom and the British
Commonwealth would need a leader someone
who would inspire confidence and speak
for them the people only problem is the
guy that God has a very severe stammer
or stutter speech impediment now the
trailer makes it look like this guy just
doesn't like public speaking but in
reality the guy stammers when he's
talking to his four-year-old it's a
little rough to watch and now the radio
has just sprung on the scene so now the
King needs to address all his subjects
on the air so you really feel like there
is just no hope for this guy so he goes
and sees a speech therapist who is none
other than Barbosa no Geoffrey Rush now
when watching the trailer I thought
Geoffrey Rush was gonna just steal the
show like he would be the supporting
character that just overshadowed
everybody not that he was bad he was
really good but call him first man
that's the guy there is no time in this
movie like no spot that I can think of
that anyone ever upstage is Colin Firth
you had never seen Colin Firth before
you never saw a movie that he was in you
would swear to god he actually has a
speech impediment he just absolutely he
was the role like Heath Ledger and the
Joker only less homicidal and everyone
did a good job in this movie everyone
just acted their asses off like Geoffrey
Rush was awesome in this movie Helena
Bonham Carter played a normal chick that
was school and she was good at it Guy
Pearce was in it he played a douchebag
he's good at playing a douchebag what
can I say like I said no one ever
upstage is Colin Firth he owns every
scene it's like it's an inspiring story
and a grand scale in the sense that this
guy needs to be able to publicly speak
in order to give the people in his
country confidence in him so they can
get through this coming worldwide crisis
and just function in general but they
keep it focused on one guy struggle with
his own disability dude that's good
filmmaking seriously and I like how this
role guy this royalties only hope and
getting through this personal crisis is
this guy this commoner who I mean
culturally speaking so much lower than
him in class but when they're in the
same room together and they're working
they're equals you see that royal people
are just normal people and now the bad
in the movie
yeah I got nothing my only gripe is I
didn't see this movie in 2010 when it
actually came out it would have been on
my top ten list easy if I had the King's
Speech is inspirational and it is
awesome tacular if you don't get
inspired by this movie you are the most
jaded prick on earth I promise you next
to the guy who wiped his own ass with
his toy story 3 ticket stub I would
recommend this movie to anybody any
human being I don't care if you're a
fascist and are kissed who was
established rule over Antarctica watch
the movie get inspired feel good and on
a side note be sure to check out schmoes
no comm from my blog that I wrote about
the entertainment business and where
it's kind of going right now I feel it's
interesting and relevant so I put the
link below go check it out and if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]